el costo en dólares de producir x
galones de pintura para madera es y
tenemos esta función de costo el costo
que depende x es igual a 3200 más 0.1 x
menos 0001 es cuadrada más 0.000 4x
pública ok
cuál es la fórmula de la función del
costo marginal se prima de x es decir lo
primero que nos pregunta este problema
es cuánto vale el costo marginal y
recuerda que el costo marginal no es
sino otra cosa que la primera derivada
del costo con respecto en este caso a x
entonces lo que vamos a buscar ese prima
de x que bueno recuerda que también lo
podemos ver como la tasa de cambio del
costo con respecto a una unidad de
producción de la cantidad de producción
que en este caso estamos hablando de
galones de pintura para madera ok
bueno pues realmente este es un
ejercicio de saber derivar y vamos a ver
quién es ese prima de x y si tú te fijas
en un principio
la derivada de este pero la derivada de
una constante siempre cero por lo tanto
no vamos a poner nada ok
después a esto lo tengo que agregar la
derivada y déjame cambiar de color la
derivada de este pero la derivada de
éste es muy sencilla esto es lo mismo
que 0,1 o 0.1 0.1
y a esto le voy a agregar la derivada de
este ok aquí tenemos que bajar esta
potencia multiplicando y me va a quedar
menos 0.002 ok y entonces pongo una
equis elevado a la potencia 2 - 1 lo
cual es uno perfecto ya esto le tenemos
que agregar la derivada de éste la
derivada de éste lo cual es más y 3 3
por 4 esto se me quedaría 0.00
y aquí me quedaría 12 hay que tener
cuidado con el punto 2 cm x elevado al
lado 3 - 1 lo cual es 2 y del ojo aquí
ya tendríamos la respuesta de esta
primera pregunta cuál es la función del
costo marginal el costo marginal se
prima de x bueno pues la derivada de s
con respecto a x o el costo marginal de
prima de x o la tasa de cambio del costo
con respecto a la producción es igual a
0.1 menos 0.002 x ok más 0.00 12 x
cuadrada ok estamos bien ahora nos dicen
redondeando al un centavo al centavo más
cercano puede ser puesto marginal de
producir el 101º el 101º galón de
pintura de madera y bueno antes de
calcular quienes se prima de siempre que
es lo que nos preguntan quiero que
entendamos este concepto bien de una
manera visual así que a déjenme ver bien
a qué me estoy refiriendo si aquí por
ejemplo
al eje al eje y lo voy a poner así no
voy a tomar aquí al eje de las x este es
mi eje x ok y por aquí por aquí tengo el
valor de 100 ok ahora sí 7 y por acá me
voy a tomar el valor de 101 de 101
galones de pintura distingan dones de
pintura e imagínate que por aquí está mi
función
mi función del costo la voy a dibujar
más o menos así tengo una función por
aquí ok y esta es mi función del costo
que va por aquí ahora si yo lo que
quiero ver es cuánto vale se prima de
100 me estoy refiriendo a ti carmen y
déjame cambiar de color cuánto vales se
de 100 aquí tengo ce de 100 ok y cuando
yo veo a se prima de 100 me estoy
refiriendo a cuánto vale la pendiente la
pendiente de la recta tangente justo
aquí déjame dibujarla por aquí aunque me
va a quedar algo más o menos así que
imagínate que esta es mi recta tangente
y por lo tanto la p
y déjenme escribirlo así la pendiente la
p
en diente ok de esta recta tangente es
igual a se prima evaluado en 100 porque
estamos en el punto 100 ok de lujo ya
sabemos quién es está pendiente de esta
recta tangente ahora lo que me piden es
que redondeado
que son centavos al centavo más cercano
cuál es el costo marginal de producir el
centésimo primer galón de pintura de
madera qué quiere decir eso bueno a lo
que me refiero es lo siguiente si tú te
das cuenta aquí tengo un cierto valor am
y déjame ponerlo con este color aquí
tengo un cierto valor para éste aquí
esté aquí que es el costo de producir
101 galones ok si yo quisiera saber cuál
es la diferencia de costo de estos 2
bueno pues realmente me tendría que
tomar la diferencia de estos dos que
tengo aquí que es justo lo que me pide
acá abajo ahora si yo lo que quiero
calcular es
la tasa de cambio o dicho de otra manera
el costo marginal redondeado a centavos
más cercano de producir el centésimo
galón realmente lo que me estoy
refiriendo es ver cuánto cambio en esta
recta tangente a comparación de un galón
de cambio es decir me voy a fijar ahora
en donde estoy parado aquí déjame ver
por aquí estoy ok y no voy a tomar con
una cierta aproximación una cierta
aproximación a lo que realmente es el
costo del nuevo galón dicho de otra
manera lo que voy a hacer es fijarme
en esta distancia que está aquí esta
distancia que está aquí la cual es 1
esta distancia que está aquí es 1 es de
101 a 100 galones ok ya eso lo voy a
multiplicar por el costo marginal el
costo marginal que es la pendiente de la
recta tangente evaluada en 100 y eso no
es ni más ni menos no es otra cosa que
multiplicado por esta altura de aquí que
es nuestra pendiente y por lo tanto
yo me fijé justo aquí en este punto de
aquí voy a obtener una aproximación de
según mi derivada de según mi costo
marginal cuánto debería de valer el
costo de mi siguiente galón si yo me
fijara aquí ambiente ponerlo con este
color en mi eje del costo algo así ok
supongamos que este es mi eje del costo
ok
aquí tendría hace de 100 déjame ponerlo
por aquí por aquí está el valor de ese
de 100 por aquí está mi valor de ce de
101 que es justo esto de aquí y si yo me
fijo en la diferencia entre ellos dos es
decir esta distancia que tengo aquí de
aquí hasta acá me estoy fijando en cuál
es la diferencia del costo de producir
de 101 galones a producir 100 galones es
decir cuánto no está apostando a ser el
siguiente galón después de 100 galones
que es justo lo que tengo aquí abajo
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que esta
aproximación a la que me refiero es
decir es decir evaluarse prima de 100 me
estoy fijando en una
estimación de cuánto es lo que cuesta
realmente de cuánto es lo que cuesta
realmente y lo voy a poner mejor por acá
estoy fijando en una aproximación aquí
de cuánto es lo que cuesta realmente el
siguiente galón según después de
producir estas 100 galones según mi
costo marginal y bueno eso no es ni más
ni menos no es otra cosa que evaluar eso
en 100 entonces vamos a hacerlo y para
eso voy a sacar por aquí mi calculadora
ya la tengo por acá y lo que quiero es
evaluar esta expresión en 100 entonces
me quedaría a 0.1
dónde está el menos menos 0.002 esto que
subes multiplica a 100 ok
vamos bien a esto le voy a sumar a esto
hay que sumarle 0.00 12 x 100 elevado al
cuadrado ok y esto la respuesta de esto
que es 11.9 es lo que va a valer ante
jaime escribirlo aquí esto es lo que
vale se prima de 100 el costo marginal
evaluado en 100 galones o de otra manera
11.9 11.9 ok esto lo estoy midiendo en
dólares dólares con respecto a galón
dicho de otra manera según mi costo
marginal el siguiente galón que voy a
producir es decir el centésimo primer
galón que voy a producir de pintura de
madera me va a costar 11.9
y bueno vamos a ver qué tan lejos
estamos del valor real redondeado am y
otra vez me voy a fijar en los centavos
en el centavo más cercano cuál es el
costo actual cuál es el costo real de
producir el centésimo primer galón de
pintura de madera y bueno para eso lo
que tengo que hacer es evaluar justo
esto de aquí pero lo que sí quiero que
me entiendas bien es que me refiero
ahora a cuánto es lo que vale la
diferencia de en el costo de producir
101 galones a comparación del costo de
producir 100 galones y qué otra manera
lo que me estoy fijando es de una manera
o de una forma real de un costo actual
cuánto es lo que cambian estos dos
costos o dicho otra manera lo que me
estoy fijando realmente es cuánto es lo
que me cuesta producir el siguiente
galón de una manera real y bueno para
eso tengo que evaluar estas dos
expresiones de aquí así que de igual
manera dejamos sacar aquí mi calculadora
ok y vamos a hacerlo con mucho cuidado
porque ahora me tengo que fijar en esta
función de aquí yo lo que quiero ver es
es a 3200 ok primero voy a calcular de
101 3 mil 200 más 0.1 por ciento 1 por
ciento 1 ok ya esto le tengo que quitar
le tengo que quitar 0.00 0.00 uno por un
101 al cuadrado por 101 en el valor
cuadrado ok ya esto le tengo que sumar a
esto lo tengo que sumar 0.000 4 que
multiplica a 101 elevado al cubo ok y
esto es igual a ok
esta cantidad de aquí entonces a esta
cantidad de aquí a esta cantidad de aquí
le voy a quitar le voy a quitar bueno
cuánto es se de 100 y para eso dejemos
al paréntesis para hacerlo con mucho
cuidado a eso le voy a quitar 3200 ok
+ + a 0.1 por ciento 0.1 que multiplica
a 100
ok ya esto le voy a quitar ok le voy a
quitar porque está dentro de los
paréntesis esta cantidad de aquí que es
0.001 que multiplica a 100 elevado al
cuadrado ok ya esto le voy a sumar le
voy a sumar porque recuerda que estamos
adentro de los paréntesis 0.000 4 que
multiplica a 100 a 100 elevado al cubo
ok y vamos a ver cuántos esto aquí lo
hice bien ok ok ok le voy a quitar esto
en mi resultado es 12 puntos y buenos
tengo que redondear al centavo más
cercano así que me quedaría 12.02 12.02
ok vamos a escribirlo
esto es 12 12.02 dólares por galón ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que realmente
no es mucho la diferencia esta
aproximación es bastante buena 11.9 a
comparación de 12.02 bueno la diferencia
es muy pequeña recuerda que ésta 11.9 la
estamos tomando como cuál es la tasa de
cambio instantánea instantánea que
estamos viendo al producir 100 galones
de pintura y fíjate bien aquí lo que
hice fue fijarme en cuál es la pendiente
de esta recta de la recta tangente justo
aquí y lo multiplique por este cambio
que era un galón ahora quiero que te des
cuenta
que
aproximación que realmente no fue nada
mala esta aproximación lo que me está
dando es un modelo lineal es decir
conforme a esta recta tangente
estoy aproximando el valor de lo que me
cuesta producir el siguiente galón
ahora date cuenta que esta no es la
gráfica de una función lineal y por lo
tanto el costo real el costo real de
producir el siguiente galón después de
los 100 galones bueno pues es esta de
aquí pero realmente no estamos tan
alejados de nuestra aproximación con el
costo marginal